Wow, barely anybody here. Surprised.
Okay.
Where is everyone?
>> Oh, forever.
>> I was just coming in real quick to talk
about the Henry. the Henry group. Um,
I'm gonna pop out, let you guys keep on
going. Uh, so the guys who are still in
class seven and survived Armageddon,
we're going to be putting you into a
different group called the Henry group.
And, uh, this is going to be a normal
pattern from now on in the class. So,
guys who survive Armageddon will
continue in that group specifically. And
it's basically think of it as like a
preparation for you guys passing the
course um going to Berica cloud things
like that you know but we're going to be
setting you up differently over there um
so this we're again we're dividing the
students up a little bit differently
going to be treating the things
differently and the Zoom links will be
in the other group will not be in Zion.
All right that's all I came in to say.
Uh, hope you guys are having a good uh,
Saturday. A little surprise there's so
few students, but oh well. I guess
that's what's happening. I'm guess life
is. Uh, do you have any questions before
I drop down and let you guys enjoy your
Saturday?
>> Do they
>> do they need the full do they need the
full link in or should we put should we
keep posting the links as as we doing
right now without the password or do we
post full links with the password? Um, I
think
>> to tell the truth in Henry, we could
probably just put a normal link in there
>> without dealing with a password. Kind of
like how the other classes are like
like the Cisco, Kubernetes, like they
don't have any links. They don't have
any password links.
>> So, Henry, I'll treat that.
>> Will it be guys from more than one class
in there?
>> I don't care if there it is more than
one class. I'm not really worried about
that.
Not at this point.
But to be for quarity, Henry is the
intermediary between Zion and the
>> cloud cloud. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Great. Um,
>> so do you expect guys to stay there for
the full time or do you expect them to
move out of there eventually?
Um it's
up in the air. It's not something I mean
ideally you go to baller cloud
>> ideally
>> but not
>> yeah but I just want to say not every
okay guys are going to get jobs in there
without passing the terraform certain
without passing SAA or PCA
>> because they passed Armageddon.
>> Yeah they pass Armageddon. So like I'll
give an example like somebody like TIQS
he would be one of these guys who would
be in Henry
definitely can get a job definitely
isn't capable but still has not pass SAA
he just keeps on failing in SAA that's
fine I don't care that act he's active
in the class he's he's doing stuff he's
one of the class leaders that's normal
but he still doesn't have the
requirements for baller to clap that's
just the way life is Right. Um
>> Okay.
>> There's other guys there could be other
guys like this who just stay in and uh
Henry for a while.
>> Okay. Okay. Um
um also um um
give some encouragement to your group
leaders since they have to send guys to
cloud proofing ground and they're
getting a lot of push back.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. I'm getting messages, but I'm
going to be honest. Like I'm just kind
of not being as like just a little more
direct with them maybe is the way to say
it. Like like getting messages like I
didn't know I was in single. I've been
there for six months, but this is news.
What do you mean?
>> Yeah.
>> Like uh well, you've used the group chat
before, so surely you knew that existed.
So there are going to be guys who are
going to have push back or going to be
having issues with with being in uh
cloud proving grounds, right? Uh and
then being removed from the main
classes. That's fine. Um guys, uh we're
men and we have to make hard decisions
and that's just a part of being a man.
And so, um, you know, I had people
pinging me this morning asking about
this or that. You know, you're already
sad. And I was like, I'm I'm not going
to do anything different. If your group
leader
says this, this, and that, and then I
don't see any evidence of you passing
Armageddon, and you are in where you're
you you put yourself in a certain
situation. I'm not going to give you an
asterisk. All right? And that's just the
way life is. And we have to make this uh
division or else the group the long-term
survivability of this group or this
process is going to be in jeopardy. So
this is why I put I've implemented these
changes. We simply put cannot have guys
who don't know the fundamentals who
aren't participating. Uh it's the big
one is not participating. if they're not
participating, they're not going to cl
uh group meetings, they're not doing
their homework, and then they're going
into this kind of class and thinking
they're going to get a job, that that's
not going to happen.
And so,
reality is happening right now. That's
good. I I'd rather reality happen now
than, you know, two weeks before they're
trying to get a job and they can't get
one at all. No one's talking to them at
all and they're like, "Hey, what's going
on?" We'll give them reality now. We're
men and this how we act,
>> right?
>> Okay. Omar, you do you have anything to
comment on this
mar?
No. Okay. He's saying that the guys are
telling him that people want to work on
their own. He's saying that he's trying
to push teamwork and we have to teach
them how to work together. Oh,
>> if they wish to work on their own and
they become they become islands, they
will sink on their own and you can have
no mercy for them.
And the the main example I have of this
is my own father.
So my co my father called himself an
island soant
and he wouldn't work with other people
and I grew up poor because of that
decision.
I never forgot it. That was his
arrogance.
That was his stupidity and delusion
believing him thinking that he should
get full benefits as a father and a
husband while being a total [ __ ] re in
regarding labor.
And I have the same direct merciless
uh viewpoint of students who work on
their own. If they weren't as rich to
work on their own, fine. They're going
to sink on their own. It's not the way
that they do not understand how this
this how the market really works. And
yeah, Indians are not working alone.
They're working in groups. So are
Chinese and Koreans.
>> That's the way they work.
>> So the Indians are like, "Hey, cool. You
just gave me an excuse to have a visa.
I'm taking your job, black man." And
that's what he's going to do.
>> Yeah. And
>> I have I have no mercy for them.
>> Go ahead, Erin.
>> No. Okay. Then I was going I'm just
going to say that, you know, ultimately
this is this is why this is why we're
here trying to work together,
>> right?
>> You have like it it it for a while,
guys. Yeah. It doesn't come naturally,
but that's the reason why we're doing it
now because you got to do it in the
office. If you don't work together now,
how do you expect to do so in the office
with someone that doesn't really care
about your personal? If you if you get
someone that cares about whether you're
breathing in the office, and that's
that's that's a that's a benefit.
>> That's wow. Wow. Wow. Look what happens.
Um, so not most companies don't care.
They just they use you as a resource.
That's it. If they can use AI and get
rid of you, they would do that. So
you're there for a reason for because
they can't find somebody else. means you
have to work with a group. And the more
you work with the group, the more likely
you're going to keep the job. That's
always true. I mean, last week I [ __ ]
up on the job. Okay, I'm just going to
honest. I I [ __ ] up. But I'm
integrated into groups. I told people
what the some of the fuckups were. Um,
that was fine. They they we took care of
it and we just continued on. And then
when I got help, I praised other people
and they're like, "Hey, cool." You know,
I got I showed other people they had
value. And by doing so, I belong a part
of the group. That's group dynamics.
It's a you have you have to understand
how to do this. Um if you don't, such is
life. I'm not going to deal with it. Uh
so I was told when a when when I was a
young man, you know, black men cannot
work together as a team. That's actually
But you see them.
>> Incorrect. But
>> NBA, NFL, baseball, military, they all
work as teams,
>> right? But the but the main the bigger
question is do they respect do they
respect another black man leading them?
I think that that may be what we what
we're facing. It's like, all right,
well, you got all all mo majority black
men here are do you respect the guy
that's telling you what you need to do?
And more often than not, they they're
wax on what we're telling them, but let
someone that looks like Aaron come in.
No offense, Aaron, but let someone that
white dude come in, tell them the same
exact thing. They'll buy it. Like, all
right. So there I So you so it's the
individual that believes that Aaron's as
cold as mine. No problem. I'll just tell
Aaron to go give him the ice.
>> Yeah. Well, ultimately, I'm going to be
the one giving the ice.
>> It's true.
>> I'm I'm brutally I'm brutal about life
because that's what I had. So, if you're
if you're getting that kind of push
back, like don't
don't even care. It's like, hey, look,
you're someplace else and then they can
go deal with um Ross and Black Muslim.
We're going to have real fun with them.
And um again talking with black Muslims
that was a good conversation today and
if they continue on from there okay if
they don't they don't but it's it's more
dealing with reality and we have to deal
with the reality of the market just the
way it is. The the main thing is just
Theo is just Dio understands that cycles
from his more talented guys are being
taken away towards guys that aren't
producing and he's like I need I need
you guys to actually do something
>> and and and if and the hope is that if
you guys are actually producing and even
are able to like start working for for
real money then that'll actually
motivate the other guys to get their
stuff in order because now they see that
their group leader is actually winning.
Well, it it may or may not. May maybe it
will, but the way I look at it is
that group leader has been successful,
right? So then later on, hopefully
there'll be more students coming on.
He'll be a group leader again and then
more people will will filter through.
Those guys who had doubt, maybe they're
going to sit there on the corner and
have doubt. I don't care. my my time and
effort or our time and effort is best
served to our students who are going to
go out and get the job
that the other guys are gonna sit there
like you know what is it in sandals and
white socks right smoking some
cigarettes on the corner we don't care
about them
>> sandals and dirty socks
I I went muking mode there I'm sorry I
had to go muke I just like oh [ __ ] it
man because I see this guys, especially
abroad. I'm like, you don't do [ __ ] like
that. Okay. But oh well. Anyway,
>> you get yourself open toe sandals and a
button-d down shirt and the wind blowing
the shirt open.
>> Yeah, you know, I'm not happy about it.
Um anyway, I have to work on some other
things inside the house and so I have to
prepare for 7.5. 7.5 should be fun today
though. So you guys go enjoy yourselves.
Um again, I will be teaching uh Lambda
on Tuesday.
There's things I want I want to start
setting some things up for Lambda. But
for now, you guys go ahead and stay
here, participate, and have some fun.
Okay, I'm taking off. Um, enjoy, and I
will see you later. Peace.
>> All right. So, let's So, good afternoon.
Let's get into it.
So,
uh,
Let's start. Let's start here.
Okay.
So,
all right. So,
we're here we're here basically to
prepare everyone for the lambdas that
deal the is going to be working with um
next week. Um so this today today will
be more so a
deeper dive and a redo of the lab that
we did with Aaron on Tuesday. So
we'll talk we're talking AWS Lambda. So
let's do
our stockation.
Uh let's see here. So let's read up on
lambda.
Oh, there we go. Centered screen.
Okay, so for the guys that say hey needs
to be needs to be larger. Okay, so
Lambda you run code without provisioning
or managing servers and you pay only for
the compute time that you consume.
There's no charge when the code is
running and you could run code for
virtually any type of application or
backend service. You guys can read that.
So basically
you have you have three tiers. You have
um
see this here.
So you have so we have three tiers. So
we have uh we have a server server is
EC2.
We have um so micro services
is uh
uh containers.
Okay. Then you have the uh silver Equals
function
as a service
uh
okay so so a server is of course you own
you own the service you own the server
okay so or better yet you are you you
own it, you run it, you manage it or or
if you're renting it from from Amazon,
you're rent you're you are capable
capable of managing the server, managing
the connectivity, managing the security,
managing the OS,
all that stuff via the shared shared uh
trust model. You're responsible for the
server. Okay,
next up would be microservices.
Microservices is where you get the whole
containerization
and orchestration. So containerization
means you are packaging a a uh some
application code and runtimes into
uh into a a prepackaged item so it could
run in in multiple environments and you
could scale it up, scale it down. uh we
could we'll get into that down the line.
So the practice of of packaging those um
packaging those applications and
runtimes into a singular item to be
distributed um that's called
containerization. So uh examples could
be docker pod man uh container deep or
container damon and then the second
portion of of microservices is
orchestration. So orchestration is how
do you want these
containers containerized applications to
be deployed in your environment. So
orchestration usually uh goes uh usually
uh is handled by Docker Swarm.
Um you can what's the other what's the
uh other one? Um what's what's the
Aaron? What's the intermediate docker?
So it's do so it's the Docker file. Um
oh goodness it's Docker Swarm which is
the orchestration one. There's a there
was a more there was an intermediary
between Docker between a regular Docker
file running it and a Docker swarm. I
forget what it is but
not not Docker image. Docker image is
basically you using you making a
container. Um but regardless
orchestration means you're you're
deploying and running your Docker
containers. Oh gohead.
>> Uh Docker Compose.
>> Yes, thank you. Docker compose. So, so
>> like orchestrating multiple containers
declaratively but on a single node.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> So, so if we say compose a single node
and then swarm is multiple nodes.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. single node
and then docker swarm is deployment on
multi node
deploy. Okay. And then kubernetes is is
it its own ecosystem of nodes to deploy
on
>> it's alternative to swarm.
Comparatively, Swarm is simpler, but
like Kubernetes is just much more like
extensible and modular.
>> Okay.
So, that's microservices.
We don't we can get into the
>> Are you trying to show them something?
>> Oh, uh I didn't didn't share the full
screen. There we go.
Okay. So server EC2 then you got your
microservices
which is containerization
and then orchestration.
Then we got serless. Serless is a
function as a service. So basically
you're so basically you are
the how I would describe it is you are
uh writing code to be run on on servers
that you're not trying to provision.
So
for example, let's say you let's say you
want to write hello world in Python.
You c you could you could have a you
could stand that up in an EC2, but you
would pay for the uptime for the EC2
for uptime for the uh reserved storage
for the networking for the uh elastic IP
to access the EC2. You have to pay for
all of those services. Now, of course,
you pay for the hour, but let's say it
needs to be up for eight hours. I will
take that'll take a like what like two
$3 or something. Who knows based on the
image you're using, right?
Microservices may be a bit cheaper, but
depending on how you deploy it, as you
can see, there's a whole lot of there's
a whole lot of options that you have.
So, it may be a bit complicated.
Servois is a way for you to run the run
your code
on a within a within a already
pre-provisioned environment that's
managed by a public cloud provider or or
a function as a service provider. So
it's it's easy way for you to get take
code that you know works, deploy it
inside of a cloud environment and you
and
uh essentially you only have to pay for
the usage of lambda or a serverless
function when it's triggered.
Why is this important? because this is a
foray into um eventdriven architecture
is a foray into events.
What does this mean? This means that
when something is done, when when
there's an action, there is a planned
reaction or there is a re there's a
there's a action there's a reaction that
happens based on something that happens
in the environment.
So, you know, let's take it an easy one.
If if you had like a family member, they
would ticklish and they decide to and
you decide to tickle them, they would
laugh.
So there's a the event was
there's a there's a vulnerability they
they're ticklish. You decide to exploit
the vulnerability. They're ticklish. You
tickle them and then they react by
laughing.
Maybe simple but that's the that's the
basis of event driven architecture.
something is tr something happens in the
environment and you you as the solutions
architect can now
uh make other things happen based on
those initial actions. So if so if
there's a if there's an event such as uh
you're someone clicks on a link
so uh what something you could do for a
lambda is you could tri once the once
the link is accessed we can trigger a a
lambda to run a function and then do and
then u and then deliver an action that
we a custom action that we may want to
have notice of on the back end. So
basically
event driven architecture is necessary
for especially for you know oh you know
here's a here's a better example. So
let's say um you have some home
security, right? you have some IoT
devices,
Internet of Things, and you want your
IoT device, your your your home security
camera to start recording
once there's movement, and you want a
you want your you want a notification
that there's movement on your specified
camera when the um when the camera
senses something. So the cameras the
camera is always receiving inputs
whether it's sunlight whether it's you
know people walking or cars driving by
or squirrels or you know raccoons in the
backyard there's always something
happening right? So if there is
something if something happens and you
know uh there's a car that drives by
then you know the trigger is whenever
there is movement you want to get a
notification saying hey there's movement
on this camera. So the event is there's
movement. The camera picks it up. The
camera then uh sends a notification or
the camera then uh triggers a
notification or push notification to
your phone via the the the security
application saying hey there is movement
on camera number four or something. So
and in that in that fashion now you have
an idea of what's going on on camera 4.
So now you can choose to act on it or
not act on it. That's the essence of
event driven architecture.
Um whenever something happens uh you can
trigger a response, you can trigger a
notification, you can trigger more
events to happen down the line. Another
example would be, you know, if there's
um let's see,
I will say that uh you know, let's say
let's say the um let's say you have a uh
a garage door opener, right? that
there's a garage door opener
and you you have a garage door opener.
So, you press the garage door opener,
you're back in your car out of your
garage, then you press the button the
opener again to close the garage door.
So, the the process to close the door is
running.
Garage doors have a infrared light at
the bottom of the track to to detect
whether a uh car or something is moving.
If that if there's an event that breaks
that line of sight or that in that
infrared light between the two posts and
something breaks it then there's then
that is an event that triggers a that
triggers a function saying hey there's
something still here we can't close the
door bring the door back up.
So that is event driven architecture.
Those are some examples of functions as
a service and uh let's let's read and I
I'll I'll give this to you guys too.
So function as a service is a blah blah
blah. Yep. Small specialized functions
uh to handle specific tasks. Let's zoom
in because people like to see things.
Instead of building entire applications,
developers focus on writing functions
which are then executed in response to
events or request. This ar this article
is your go-to resource for understanding
and implementing functions as a service.
Okay.
So developers, right? Right. We we read
that.
So typically event driven and executed
in response to triggers or requests such
as HTTP database or timebased events.
Okay. Developers don't have to handle
infrastructure. Right? Instead they
focus on writing code for individual
functions. The platform provides and
scales underlying resources. Okay. So
what is so you have a web app which then
goes to okay yeah this is true. So you
have web app which then is met
to a API gateway. So this API gateway we
would refer so if we were dealing with
if we were if so let's say that there
are servers on the back end let's say
that there are EC2s back here right if
there are EC2s instead of if there are
EC2s back back here back if there are
EC2s over here what would this be what
would the API gateway be if not if if we
had EC2s over here what would the API
gateway
man. So, no one knows. Okay.
>> A router. Interesting.
So guys, if you look at this diagram,
although it it is microervices,
just
let's pretend
>> let's pretend it's not.
>> Oh, no, no, no. Not all of the We need
one line of them like Okay. So,
yeah, there. What does that look like
now?
Data
logic.
It's like a three tier system.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, what would So, what would the
API gateway serve if you if we were
doing all this with EC2s instead of
serverless? What would the API gateway
be instead?
>> Would it be part of the application
layer?
>> Think AWS services.
It would be like the user.
>> Huh? What does that mean?
>> No, I see the right answer in the chat,
but they're shy. I don't want to say it
out loud.
>> It's fine.
>> All this gaming do.
What does So what does a gateway do?
Let's not even worry about API.
What does a gateway do?
It helps with um traffic flow,
>> right?
It does. So,
how in what ways does it help with
traffic flow?
Um, I guess um
I guess it's more like a
like a doorway to like the wider
internet if um if what we're building is
supposed to connect to like the the
public internet
or it could be a gateway to maybe like
our on premises environment.
Okay, that's that's fair. So,
through class 7 so far, have we worked
with any of these gateways?
Yeah. Okay. How
well this is your first first layer of
I don't know what you'd call it. uh per
permission like it would contact
whatever is in like layer 2 and see
if like where it's you're supposed to be
pointed to. You have permission to get
in and which resource in there that you
need to get into. Like if if there's two
so much traffic
then it it uses uh
it directs the traffic to wherever it's
supposed to go. All right.
explain it.
>> Okay. So, if that's the case, what what
uh services would you guys if you since
we've worked with this previously, what
services
um layer 1, layer two, or layer three?
Give me a service for each one. So, what
would be layer what would be
Well, we didn't do much of layer three,
but I'll give you guys this one. So,
layer three is is data. So data would be
um what's it called? Uh Aurora uh RDS.
That's that's what it is. RDS relational
database service,
right? So that's layer three. Layer
three is database. Okay. So let's say I
need I need you guys to come up with
layers one and two. So,
who wants to go first?
I guess for for layer one that would be
um similar to a load balancer,
>> right?
full balancer.
See, undo.
Yep.
Okay. So if layer one's load balancer
and layer three is the databases that we
haven't really touched yet, well what
would layer two be?
Your your processing layer.
>> Okay. What service?
>> EC2.
>> Yep.
So,
so, so this is, so this is how servo is
matches up with what you guys have done
already. So layer one, we could use that
as the load balancer or the or the API
gateway which is basically
blocking
which which is the which is the front
door for your um for network access from
the external to your internal services
slashprocesses.
So we could call that layer one, the
application layer and the compute layer
that we've we've meshed that. So in the
layer two that's usually handled by the
EC2s.
And then layer three is the data layer
which is RDS/ Aurora which we haven't
really uh ted on but it's useful.
So,
grab this.
Now, Aaron has something better here.
And I'll clear my screen so that we can
look at Aaron's all drawings.
Okay. So, what we got here? So, we have
a client
and then client goes to API gateway.
Yep. And then the API gateway goes to
the lambda
and then lambda goes back to the Dynamo
DB.
Uh and then it goes back to lambda then
goes to API gateway
and then it can go to
go to cognto
for identity. You can go to CloudFront.
You can go to Route 53 there. There's
HTTPS
certificate manager for Route 53 and API
gateway which is which is also stuff
we've done before. This is a good one.
This is good. So this so the majority
>> I would just tag on.
So
this
things get fancier here. Here is
web
layer. Web layers connected to the API
gateway. So static stuff is in
CloudFront.
And then
when you use API, it's going to go to
the API gateway. API gateway is going to
decide
which service they need to use.
>> Yeah. Based on the event bridge, based
on the rules that you set up in the in
the uh lambdas and the triggers that you
set up in the vent bridge.
So this would be like our
logic
and then of course this
data.
But as we get more and more into like a
cloud native usages of this, it's going
to break away from that. That's what
like that white paper is all about as
explaining.
Uh they may not, you know, really need
the traditional three tier design
like they start calling them like in
tier apps stuff because you may not it's
not like like with that one for example,
you you don't need like a web server.
You could just use CloudFront
and combine your static assets with the
CDN.
But you saying that we have options as
engineers.
>> Options?
>> What? No way.
I don't know. I have options.
Okay. So,
uh at this point, are there any
questions regarding
uh what the basics of lambda? Cuz I do
want to get into the lab, but
you know, don't want to we'll go any
questions regarding what lambda is, how
it's similar to what you've done
already.
uh going to set up. We go into this
setup briefly.
All right. So concepts uh functions are
the building blocks small independence
unit independent units of code. Uh a
function does not store data between
calls is stateless. That's why we have
to have the the database behind it
because
because there's no hard drive. There's
no hard drive. There's no
there it's a the lambda is a is
purpose-built only if you want to run
what you tell it to run. But if you want
to store something, then you definitely
need to have
storage behind it, which is why dam
Dynamo DB is usually attached to it. uh
willingly have a question.
>> Okay. So, I don't know if this sounds
crazy, but does Lambda operate similar
to a web hook?
>> It can.
So, describe a web hook.
>> Whenever something's pushed um to the
repository, it triggers it and then it
runs the Jenkins code that's in
in the repo.
>> Okay. What's the What's the initial
event?
>> Um the apply
>> initiate.
>> Okay. So the so the so you do so you're
doing a uh apply. Okay.
Uh apply where what triggers the So if
we're talking web hook, what triggers
what what's the initial trigger that the
webbook has to wait on?
uh when you're pushing code to your repo
from Terraform.
>> Okay.
>> Like you know like an event or whatever
like whatever
you know
>> right so the initial event is you doing
a get push to a repo.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. So
what so what role does the So that's the
event. So now what role does the web
hook play in getting the pipeline to
start
it triggers the Jenkins code
which is part of running the pipeline
well you know building the pipeline up.
>> Okay. So you so that is so that's an
example of you
setting up a event driven architecture
where you
do one action in one area you're working
it in GitHub you did a get push from
your console on your computer you did a
get push and then because you built a
trigger
called a web hook as as well as you
attached that web hook to a existing
pipeline that you have and the pipeline
is is is looking for that event to
happen because you did that work. Now
that event driven architecture is set up
so that now when we make a push to your
GitHub, your pipeline which is
configured to to be listening to that to
to that web hook will now do a pipeline
run.
So it's another example of event driven
architecture. Wanders can be the same
where it could be where Wanders could be
the thing that does a triggering or
Wanda could be the thing that is
triggered by a prior action.
All depends on how you want to set it
up.
>> Okay, I get it.
>> Thank you.
>> Yep. No problem.
No problem. But that's but that but but
that's why you know um that's why you
know the the web hook is a good example
but I want you guys to understand that
you know it could be the awambda is not
a static thing where it has to be used
only in this way. This is where you know
this is deep waters for myself and Aaron
because we don't really utilize lambdas
a lot in class but we're getting into it
which is fine.
the fun the the part the part of the
part that we lean on is just the
fundamentals and linking it back to what
we've already done in class. So if you
want to so that's why you know you guys
doing the the um the geek assignment
running the pipeline via uh uh get push
the web hooks all that plays into
understanding event driven architecture
and why why it uh how powerful it can be
because ultimately if you can
because this because ultimately this is
the small this is a small this This is
the start of trying to basically
automate and script everything.
If you have a multitude of scripts, a
multitude of processes, a multitude of
read readouts that you want,
event- driven processing
and event- driven architecture is the
way to accomplish that. Um, finally when
it comes to the companies, companies
would love to have this, but this is
this is uh very esoteric and they need
they need people who know how to set
this kind of stuff up in the cloud
and usually the people who can set it up
are extremely unique. You have people
who are who know what they're doing
inside of the cloud, but they also know
how to code because again uh usually
function as a service. It's applied to
software development and they're looking
for software developers to understand
the cloud and they the majority of them
don't don't have an interest in doing
so. they have an interest in doing what
they know how to do and the cloud is a
whole different uh deployment method
that they have to worry about which
takes away from what they're trying to
focus on.
Okay. So, um if there are any other
questions then you know feel free to
raise your hand but uh I'll just keep
reading these uh reading these bullet
points and then we'll get into build get
into the lab. Um so functions talked
about that event triggers. So this is
where the web hook comes in. So
functions are typically triggered by
events such as HTTP requests which is a
web hook, database changes, bio uploads
or timers. These triggers initiate the
execution of the corresponding function
allowing for event driven architecture.
If you have an alarm clock on your
phone, that's an event driven
architecture.
Why? You set your you set your alarm
clock for 6:00 in the morning. That's a
function you want. So after a certain
amount of time, you want your phone to
start ringing and to try to wake you up.
That's event driven architecture based
on time. Uh file uploads. Um, so what's
a good one for a file upload?
Um,
>> S3.
>> Yeah. Yeah. S S3 is a good S3 is a a
solid answer.
Um, S3 is S3 for file uploads. Database
changes. You can um
simple one would be, you know, you get
an email when something changes on on
within a a database. Not you guys aren't
you guys aren't there yet inside the
class, but I can't really think of a
good example in the real world. Um,
okay. Serverless
functions as a service abstracts away
the need to manage servers or
infrastructure. Developers don't need to
provision, scale, or maintain servers.
The platform handles tasks automatically
allowing for serverless computing model.
Okay.
Function as a service follows payer use
billing model where users are charged
based on the resources consumed by their
functions such as compute time and
memory usage. This model offers cost
efficiency
especially for sporadic workloads. So if
it's not used on a regular basis then
yeah do pay per use. However, if you
want it to be used on a consistent
basis, it may be more cost effective to
build a server because you expect a
certain amount of usage.
Um, scalability uh platforms
automatically scale functions in
response to workload demands. Functions
can handle varying levels of traffic,
ensuring high availability and efficient
utilization.
And functions are stateless by design,
meaning they don't store information.
Any required state must be managed
externally through databases or external
storage services.
Okay.
All right. So, let's see what we got
here. Yeah. So, how it works? Upload
function code to cloud provider account.
Define function triggers such as a API
call or a click on a on a link. And then
the provider runs the function code when
triggered. So this is what we're
actually going to be doing today. This
is perfect. So we can stop. So we'll
stop here. But this is a good article.
Um it's a it's a good summary cuz I'm
learning something from them. So uh I
mean I I know that I'm behind you guys,
but um this is a good article. Geeks for
Geeks always has good content. So what
we'll do is make a new function
and let's pick a new let's pick uh
uh let's pick Thailand.
See if we can do it. See if we can do
this in Thailand.
So you pick a region, whatever region is
your default. I'm just doing it in a
different region because that's what
that's where I want to do it. So we're
going to so let's see let's look at this
the steps. So sample oh I just took the
sample code. Okay. Okay. So first things
first let's create a function.
Okay. So we'll create from create a
function and we're going to author from
scratch. And we'll just start with a
simple hello world. We don't want to do
anything crazy. We just want to get it
to work for the first time.
So, I'm going to call it today 418.
Um,
Samba
building.
So, I'll name I named it this.
Then for the runtime, I want Python
because I don't know these. I'm not a
I'm not a coder. I'm I will never say
I'm a coder. I'm never say I'm I'm a
developer. But I but Python, I can say I
can work with Python.
Okay. Uh by default, Lambda will create
an execution role with permissions to
upload logs to Amazon Cloudatch logs.
That's what we want.
Then custom settings. Uh doable
execution. Uh don't need that. Each two
capacity provider don't need that.
Additional settings.
We don't need any of these. So
only thing I did was I named it and I
chose Python.
Okay. Create function. Orange button.
Okay, I am permission was created and
the function is now up and um I'm shown
different things.
That's cool.
Let's dismiss.
Okay,
so let's so let me keep my notes
rolling.
Okay.
Okay. So, Python
um
building
in
AP
Souththeast
7.
Okay.
Okay. So,
so what we got here? So, we have this
code saying hello from lambda.
So before we get into
the other nicities that we have to
configure such as the land such as the
um the IM rule
um any questions at this All right.
>> Doesn't seem like it. Okay.
Okay. So,
>> all right. Bring them in here where I'm
at.
What's up?
Sorry. All right, Mike.
>> No worries. No worries.
Okay. All right. So,
okay. We can work with this.
So, what I'll do is
right. So, for the time being, I'm going
to edit my I'm going to edit this code
and I'll give you guys what I I'll give
you guys edited code. So, I'm going to
paste.
Oh, wow.
Okay. And I'm going to give you guys the
same code. So, this is the this is the
first block of code that we're that
we're going to use.
Okay. So,
I'm again I'm limited on Python.
If you guys want Python courses then
work with work within that uh Serge's
Python class. I think it meets uh once
or twice a week but Serge goes through
the the ins and outs of Python. So
definitely look into it. I I need to
look into it. So
we have a Python function here. So the
Python function is importing JSON as a
library and
then it's defining a then a uh it's
defining a a function called lambda
handler. Well it's not function but I'll
just call this function for the time
being.
Okay so what's happening here? Line four
is printing text saying hello from
lambda. Line five is printing a function
that says event is the event that is
referenced up here.
And then the and then uh the return
codes.
This has to do with what what you guys
will see inside of Cloudatch logs
whenever the Lambda code is triggered.
So this is a basic one and if I if I
fumbled through it then I fumbled
through it
but let's see here. So say so we saved
it or sorry not saved. So so in the when
we're working in the console or in the
guey right we have to deploy. So once
we've once you've copied and pasted the
new code into the into the little VS
code uh
enter the VS code box here you have to
click the port.
Okay. And then the successfully updated
the function. So this is good. Okay. Get
rid of that. Okay. So,
next up is we have to
create a a role.
So, what we'll do is
open up another tab.
Go to or then in search bar we'll go to
am
And then we'll click on rolls
and what we'll and what we'll have to do
is we'll create another roll.
As you can see, I created one for TW uh
on on Tuesday for the lab that Aaron
did. So, we're just going to redo it.
So, going to create a roll.
So, I'm in So, right now I am in AM
roles. IM roles. I'm creating a RO.
Okay. and I'm going to select AWS
service to to execute actions in this
given role. Okay. So I'm going to choose
so uh so within AWS service
I'm going to choose lambda.
Okay.
So I'm choosing lambda. I'm choosing
lambda.
Then we'll say next
and
let's see.
So,
so uh on the on step two after I
selected my trusted entity as lambda on
step two I'm going to in the where I'm
searching for permission policies I'm
going to type in lambda lambda
as I can spell then
I'm going to select basic execution rule
so lambda basic execution rule
Uh,
okay.
Cloud watch EC2
X-ray. Interesting. Okay. You may I may
change this. I may double back and
change this, but I'm going to stick with
the Lambda basic execution rule for for
for now.
Okay. the lambda basic execution role.
Let's add that to notes.
>> Yeah, I got a question. Um, there's like
four basic execution rules. Do we pick
any one?
We're picking one that says AWS Lambda
basic execution rules.
So AWS Lambda basic execution rule. Um,
where are the other three that you see
or what are they called?
>> It's up under, but I noticed that they
were customer managed. So, we want the
one that's AWS managed.
>> This these are likely ones I've done in
the past. Lambdas I've done in the past.
So, I'm not even worrying about
not even worrying about these ones cuz
these ones are likely attached to an
existing lambda. That exactly. See,
>> you can see I can see that. So you guys
may not see it because you may you guys
may not have done as many as I've done
in the past, which is expected, but you
know, if you guys have toyed around with
it, it will have the ARN that's attached
to a prior lambda you've done. So I did
EC2 tagging lambda before. Uh that this
was the lambda that I did uh on on
Tuesday with Aaron.
This was the lambda that we did that was
named after the boss boss
you know EC2 config change lambda. So
these so whenever you create a new
um lambda and you attach the AWS managed
basic execution role these will pop up.
So so I'm not so I'm not worried about
these. I usually stick to the AWS
managed roles or AWS managed permission
policies unless it's something I created
manually like what we like what we had
to do in Armageddon
mission boundaries we can we can uh
leave that alone.
Okay. And then ro detail is let's name
it. 48
uh oh
salsa
daily
and
okay so role name is this allows lambda
functions to call AWS services on my
behalf. F. Select trusted entities.
Cool. Add permissions. Add tags.
And then we'll do create roll.
Okay. So, here's my roll. I need to copy
that.
Put in my notes.
two.
Perfect.
I am basically
see here
name is that okay am I missing anything?
No, probably but we'll work with it.
Okay. So
at this point we have a we have a lambda
and then we have a
we have a lambda and then we have a
execution rule.
Do are there any questions at this
point? Does anyone help?
Is anyone lost?
If if if not then I'll try to we'll try
to to start the triggering of this
lambda.
All good. He says all right cool. All
right. So so the IM role is created.
That's great. So now
what now the next step is let's
configure this lambda.
Okay.
So let's start with general config.
I'm going to So the lambdas are
notoriously quick. Okay.
So we're in edit basic settings. The
lambdas are notoriously quick. You don't
well you know because it's because you
don't want to be running forever. You
know it the default is set to 3 seconds.
I'm going to set it to 15 seconds. Okay,
just so that the code has a chance.
So I So what I did is I changed the
timeout to 15 seconds. And then the
execution role, I'm also changing that
to
my custom role that I just created,
sambar lambda ro. And I looked at my
notes and that's the role I have. Okay.
customize
um
so uh time out
aution
So
uh
I am way in step
two.
Okay, quick click save.
So now it's 15 seconds. Okay, that's
general config. Next up is the trigger.
Uh not there's there's no trigger yet.
One will a trigger will come.
Execution rule was there. That's good.
Destination,
no destination just yet. Environment
variables.
Uh, no environment variables, no tags,
no need for VPC,
no need for RDS database right now.
Monitoring and operating tools, fileatch
logs. This is how this is. So what I
will say we we will be so I'm going to
click on my my pile watch log for the
lambda because this is how I can tell
that the invo that the lambda has been
in has been triggered invocated and then
it's actually running like I expect it
to run. Uh while group does not exist in
this
region.
No w group. Do I have to create one
function arnation
text?
Okay,
let's check it out.
Should already be there.
Oh, maybe it's
check.
also
also correct. Okay,
so yeah, thank you for that. Thank you,
Kevin. All right, so let's try
destinations
destination.
No, that's not it. What did he do to
him? What did he do to
let's see treasure
gateway
that gateway
not a
S3 SNS SQS stable DB in Kinesis. Nope,
that's not it.
So, let's see here.
Nope. General config triggers
permissions.
See,
no aliases.
code source code property runtime
and local synchron
so what I'm trying to do is Aaron on
Tuesday he was able to generate a um a
URL for his lambda f for his lambda
function so I'm just trying to do the
same thing
so API interactive web
application load balancer No need time.
>> Um I think that's under configuration
function URL
and then you click create function URL.
So mine isn't here unfortunate.
So maybe maybe it's in the it's in a
given region. Let's check
configuration. Yep, it's regional. Okay,
no problem. So, let's recreate.
So,
double X8.
Yep.
All right. So, in the meantime, I'm
going to bomb this away. Bomb my the uh
the resource I create in Thailand. I
I'll get rid of it because
can't have two things of the same name.
Drag delete.
Okay.
So, create
use another roll.
And here here it is. I love naming
convention.
Okay.
So, additional config.
Don't need any of this other extra
stuff. 14. Okay.
Great. Fun.
Christmas dismiss.
Okay.
Uh
yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Unfortunate that
function URL wasn't in uh Thailand.
It's not it's not up to par just yet.
Okay. So, config
edit
sambar
roll 15 seconds.
Okay. Function URL.
I knew I wasn't bugging. Okay. Uh, no
need for
uh authentication.
Okay. Click save.
Okay. So now we have a function URL.
Good.
So now
what else am what else did I skip over?
Oh, I didn't I did not uh deploy the
code
event context. Yeah. Okay. Do that.
Updating the function. Yep. Save
function. Beautiful. Okay. So let's give
it a shot. So we got config function URL
copy
tab paste
and I get hello from lambda. Okay, this
is good. Hello from lambda. And then
let's also check the logs because the
logs are incredibly important.
So let's check it out.
Okay, then we got log streams attached
to this lambda.
And then I got hello from lambda. Cool.
At uh 1530. Yep. 3:30.
Yep. Hello from Lambda. Good. Good.
Good. Good. Good. Okay. So, I'm going to
throw this into the chat
or yeah, I'll throw it into the chat for
deliverable
to show that to prove that it works and
then
uh for guys who are following following
along, I would implore you guys to do
the same.
See here.
How else can we have fun?
Okay. All right. Mr. Tover.
Hello from Lambda. Okay.
>> Hey, Rob. Quick question.
>> What's up?
>> The permissions policy, you only went
with the basic execution role, nothing
else.
>> That's correct.
>> Okay. Yeah, I got a 403. I I want to
redo it.
>> Okay.
Um
uh
since we got time, let's go into the
role I built out. Let's take a look. So
some say they want the role.
Okay. So it's only basic execution role
which is create log group create log
stream and put log events and then
resource could be anything.
Um
and then for the lambda big
I made sure that in general config click
on edit and I chose my custom role that
I created today.
So usually it will say you know if if
you're using the the the cookie cutter
uh lambda uh role if the lambda is using
the cookie cutter role that was created
when you when we first created the
lambda it will look like this lambda
basic role and then some you know alpha
numeric characters.
I can tell that when I create the role,
I don't have these these random alpha
numeric characters. So, I know that it's
mine.
Um,
okay. Cancel. Okay. So, now let's let's
have a little bit of fun cuz people like
fun. People are people like having fun.
People are fun people.
Okay. So let's do
my name is
Rob and I am a
risk
and
uh
a booty
at
Okay, one more.
Oh, no.
No, no. Um,
I will be
letting
uh what's what's called
room.
Okay.
Yep. There you go. My name is Rob. I am
a brisket balini and big boy Latina
advocate. I'll be making x amount
through deal university. So, we're
having fun.
Uh,
and then let's also change this code.
The
invocation was successful.
Okay. So all I'm doing is I'm just
adding extra lines, customizing what
we're doing here. So that when we try to
run the service again or try to visit
the the website, the website is a
trigger which then the website is a
lambda and the lambda triggers uh cloud
watch log to show up. So let's go to
configuration. Let's grab the link
again.
Copy.
Paste. Enter.
Ah, okay. So, hello with a lambda. The
invocation was successful.
Okay. So I'm guessing
if this if this was the JSON dump that
came in from the website
then
what will be shown in the cloudatch logs
will be this. So let's take a look.
So cloudatch
we'll go to the lambda basic we'll
refresh
and then this one was 1536. Okay. 336.
And then here are my here are my my
readouts. Hello from Lambda. My name is
Rob. I'm a Biscuit Balini and Big Boy
Latina advocate. I'll be making 365
annually through Theo University.
Okay. So, this is so my invocations are
working.
So,
uh let's see here.
I don't need to do that. We can do like
this
screenshot.
Bam.
So, if you guys were able to make
customizations,
then
throw the throw the code inside of chat
or throw your your link inside of the
chat
and throw the screenshot of the crowd
log so that we can see that, hey, things
are working. We can see the custom code
we put into the the log as well as the
um as well as the HTTPS response. Hello
from Lambda. The invocation was
successful. So
let's see what you guys got.
And at this point
uh there there was one other thing I
want I wanted to try which was the
uh notification but we're running up on
time and I want to make sure that if
guys want to get this working
then spend the time troubleshooting.
Kev see what Kev got.
Hello. I love Oh, a man of culture. Case
of Dillas. Nice. There you go. Take off
your shoes when you walk through the
door. Exactly. Respect my floor.
Okay. Good. Good.
No, not that one. But this is good.
Okay. All right. While I'm waiting for
other guys to
uh get working, is there anyone that's
stuck?
>> No, no one that's stuck.
I'm still getting a message forbidden
error and I'm trying to figure out why.
I'm checking the AM
and it's set up with that basic
execution role unless I did something
and deleted it.
>> Okay,
>> let's share screen and let's take a
look.
Thanks.
Okay. Um,
did I do the whole screen share?
>> Yeah, we can see you for
>> Okay,
cool.
>> Okay. So, what have you built so far?
>> So, let's go.
That little thing at the top is
annoying. Where am I?
I am policies lambda. Let's go with this
one.
>> Okay,
the code's in.
>> Yep. Open. Okay.
>> Yep.
Next up, let's go to uh fig.
Okay.
Oh, see there it is. Okay. So,
this one right here, right? So, click on
edit.
>> Yeah, we don't we don't want
authentication because because AM means
that it has to be someone inside the
environment to actually trigger it. But
if it's public internet then we can't
have IM running on public internet.
That's where the whole cognto comes into
play. But uh yeah, for now just click
none and then scroll down and uh yeah,
click save and give it a shot.
>> Okay, cool. Thank you.
>> Yep. No problem.
>> I put that in my notes.
>> Yes. Yes. The almighty notes. Okay. Put
my screen back up.
Okay. Anyone else having issues
with the lambda invocation?
Okay. Boom.
Okay. Let's check out Mr. Tover. Mortal
Kombat. All right. All right. I rock
with it.
Uh, new Neo Geo.
Oh, good. Let's Neo Geo Pocket. Good
times.
All right, then. Let's check out
William.
I am a quad engineer. Indeed you are,
sir. Let's check this out. My name is
William and I'm a quad engineer.
Beautiful.
Beautiful. All All in due time. Okay.
Couchi did the first one. Cool. So
they'll do the edit
at some point.
Serverless execution runtimes v3. Uh oh.
Um a vector graph. Interesting.
Okay.
I'll bite. I'll take a look.
Sure. Let's try Brave.
Oh, it's fancy. event signal
orchestrator
containerized run times virtual
execution.
Uh this is
looks good to me. Looks fancy to me.
So yeah, good work bash
where interesting. Okay.
All right. anyone else that has issues
that wants to get this working.
Um the last part of the lab would be a
um would be to build out the the um the
SNS notification.
Um that's not too too hard. Um Aaron
provided that code and I will provide
that code to you guys.
So
you do there is there is one aspect of
the code that you have to edit
and you have to set a variable
environmental variable
uh in your in your lambda when it comes
to Aaron's code but outside of that it's
pretty straightforward.
So that's so that's Aaron's code for the
um for the second half of the lab which
is um setting up uh as email
notifications whenever a lander is
triggered
but
uh since we since we may be short on
time don't want to
we could probably do it if we push okay
behold let these hookas Oh,
mint.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Let these hookers burn. Got to let them
burn, brother.
>> Oh. Oh, we talking about the woman. Oh,
I'm talking about hookah. We talking.
>> Oh, no. Yeah. No, that hookers. Let
these hookers burn.
>> Ah, I feel
know. Hey, a man, a fellow man of
culture. I like and empanadas. There you
go.
Nice.
There we go. That's what I like to see.
All right. Matinez and Hey. Hey. If
someone if someone wants to go claim
Southeast Asia, man, the the the tie
chicks I hear. I hear they're waiting
for men to know swoop them up. Latafia
years waiting for men to swoop swoop
them up. So guy claimed them with your
lambda code.
Oh, double double antandra from uptown
Jamaican poppy. Oh, there you go.
I got nowhere else to go.
Got nowhere else to go.
There you go.
Make sure to send me that um that quash
logs, Charles. Okay, good work. See,
couchy
cuz I'm at where the money reside. There
you go. You You just go where the money
flow. That's all.
That's where we That's where we be at.
We just go with the money flow.
>> Swimming upstream like some salmon.
>> Exactly. I swear I saw an article on
Lafia's gender ratio issue this morning,
man. Right on time, Aaron.
We They are obviously in need of Cloud
Row to fix these issues. We just need to
get over there.
Oh man. Good, good, good, good, good,
good, good. So, I I co-signed this. I'm
at where the money reside. Money reside
with Qu. We need the H1B some brothers
over there. Listen, man.
If you get n like we I on one hand, I am
with you. On the other hand, I don't
need no passport pooky going over there
messing it up. They're already messing
up my beloved Colombia, man. Walk is
hot. No,
>> brother. I don't I don't even want to
get on that, man. And I've been tearing
stuff up in my house about that, man.
>> Yeah. Like the La Miger is now at the
airport. Anyone that got like more than
like five rubbers is now getting caught.
>> Oh my gosh, man. It's terrible.
>> Yeah, man. So, like I Columbia's too hot
right now. The sisters going to Columbia
talking about, "Oh, well, why are you
going over Columbia? You should do this
when you're in Colombia. You going for
sex." And I'm like, "Oh, man. Now, now
you can't have no fun.
>> Sure can.
>> So, gota be gota be moving on the low,
man. So that if we got the H-1B flowing,
then like you already know they're
showing up. Like they already
>> like what happened? They already got
Panama
now. They got Colombia. Only a matter of
time until Brazil until they get to
Brazil. But Brazil ain't having that.
So, here's hoping. Yep. There you go,
Charles. There you go. I like this.
Y'all do y'all are event driven
engineers. I like this, man. This is
good. This is good. Okay. Y'all y'all
y'all doing this so well. Y'all y'all
worry about Colombia as a backup plan.
Y'all y'all going to find somewhere else
that's better than Colombia,
man. Man, man. Okay. So any any other
questions regarding the lab regarding
event driven architecture? Theo got
class at 4, but I want to give you guys
some moments if you guys want to
troubleshoot or if you have any
questions and now's the time to ask.
Let's see here. Rumble. That's damn
right. Rumble, young man. Rumble.
>> [ __ ] Take my ass to the coffee region.
Take me ass Take my ass to the hills, to
the Campo. Find me a a ranchera. Find me
a chick that rides horses and and feeds
cows.
>> Lord have mercy.
>> I'm a simple man, man.
>> Yeah, I I understand. That's the way.
Hey, that's it right there. That is
>> Hold on. Hold on. Since since I have a
phone, I found I found this. Let me
Where where was it? Uh, let me let me
find it. Uh, we're out of the way. Fina,
where's Fina?
>> Fina's farm.
>> Oh [ __ ]
Okay. Wait. Damn.
Damn. I need to take my I need to do my
Dingo again. [ __ ]
All right. Where was Where's I found I
found a nice shorty. Uh I put her in in
backyard.
Where Where's she at?
Oh man. Hold on. No, I'mma find vacation
house. Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Got have that have that have that on the
ocean.
Uh well, you know, we have
>> Baria,
>> not Baria. Uh Santa Marta.
>> Okay.
>> In the same in the same area and you
know you know this is right next to
Veneuela, which is where I want to be.
So
>> you and me both, brother. I heard I've
heard Santa Marta is very nice, man.
>> Yep. It's It's nice. It's not It's not
pookied out. It's still out the way.
>> So, we working on it. Uh, let's see
here. I I got I got to show you guys the
the one the one I found. Hold on. Uh,
where she at?
Oh, beautiful.
Um,
okay. Yeah.
I think she's Colombian. I'm not sure.
Can't tell.
But if y if y'all if y'all can't. So,
okay. All right. Qu So, pretty much if
no one got questions, class is over. But
this is where I want to be at. This is
where I want to be at. Okay. That's
That's where I want to be at. Where?
Give me them hills.
Give Give me the clouds, fresh air, and
whatnot.
Wind and whatnot. But, you know,
>> was she like a professional biker? She's
a She's a singer.
She's
>> Well, I'm telling y'all, stay stay
focused, guys. Stay focused.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Cuz I I I ain't ask for much. Oh,
been
got them got them grandpa slides on
walking around farm. Let me let that be
me, man. Yeah. Get that that cow in the
corner. Absolutely.
So, I just I just I just need y'all to
stay focused, man. Cuz this right there
this this could be you, but you playing
sunset in the background. Could be you,
but y'all playing. Y'all playing with
this, man. I need y'all to get this
stuff done.
Oh goodness.
Oh yeah. And trust trust us. We got we
got people who are in the field man. We
got we got people who are ready to go,
ready to you know explore. So this is
and she's a diamond dozen out there.
Well well maybe like maybe like one like
what 200. But yeah is it organic? You
can find one that You can find one that
is organic.
>> You sure can.
>> I'm not worried about this. She got she
for for every one of her, there's
probably like 10 more of her that got
something that's off about it, but you
can fix it. I'm not worried about that.
Vinka for sale in La Pintala, Colombia.
Let's take a look.
Checking you're not a bot. I wish I was.
knows you're Nigerian.
>> It does. Does.
Good find. Good find. Look at this.
>> Look at this, man. Okay. Three. That's a
house in Texas.
Three. Can y'all pay that? Are y'all
willing to work,
>> right?
>> Are y'all will pay for this?
If it's 348 cash up front,
okay, that's that's a bit tall. But if
it if it was like a regular real estate
deal over there and you were able to
like finance it a bit more, you may have
to put like what 20% down because it's
foreign.
But let's see. Uh
>> I think it depends on the country like
how chill they are with that. Yeah,
>> you're putting 68
>> 68 down.
>> Yeah. So, let's say Go ahead.
>> If if you do if you do it right and you
find yourself a reputable agent in the
area, I'm not 100% how they do it in
Colombia, but you can make a deal where
they'll take down their commission a
little bit, thereby letting you bring
less to the table up front and then buy
yourself a little time to pay them back
whatever that rest over would have been.
>> Right. But it's so just let's if we're
doing 25%.
That's 85,000.
So 85,000 let's say you're let's say
you're making
uh
let's say let's say you're making one
uh by 12.
So, let's say if you're making 130,
that's 10 $10,800
gross
per per month, right? Let's say net
let's say net uh let's call it.
>> Wait, time out.
>> Okay,
>> sorry. I just Googled this. And
apparently, you need 30 to 50 down as a
foreigner.
>> And the interest rates for foreigners
are like anywhere from 10 to 18%.
Okay,
>> let's do those maths.
>> 340 26 262
>> like 100 110k down something like that.
>> Yeah,
>> it's not not too crazy.
>> Yeah, but and it's like it
>> you have two jobs. It's you just put
your second salary.
>> This is true.
>> That's for real.
And if you and you you spend a year
working and then now you have a nice
little hideaway in nice little fina in
Colombia rolling hills. Oh
>> oh my goodness.
>> Does it have solar?
>> Does it have solar? Well, man, they put
some Starlink there and then you're
good.
>> Absolute Starlink. Oh, they got the
gate. Oh, hell.
>> Now talking about who used to live
there.
>> Yeah. Who used to And can we get rid of
these goggles up top, man?
I'm superstitious.
Oh [ __ ] Oh, this is beautiful. Oh,
there's your solar.
>> Yo. Yep. They got solar.
>> We're good.
Look at this. This is This is beautiful.
Great. Great find, man. Great find. And
they got jacuzzi there, too. Oh, man.
>> You can rent it out for movies if you're
not home.
>> Like, it's that type of house.
>> Look. Look at Look at that. And y'all
and this this is cable for like like two
two people in class could could get this
and split it. Two work two guys are
working. No problem.
>> Solar hot water. accepts
>> water takes.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep.
>> Induction hot plate though. That's
botched.
>> Induction hot. Where you where you see
induction hot? Oh, there you go.
>> Except crypto.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. So, this is all good,
man. And it's and it's an hour outside
Medí.
>> Security.
>> Security. It's big time. So, this is
good. I like this. I like this a lot.
But
man, y'all got to stay motivated.
Whether it's property, whether it's
buying something like this, whether it's
being outside the cities, I don't care
how, but y'all got to keep stay keep on
it. And tell tell and don't to them
dudes that were struggling
who didn't do Gche, go tell them like,
listen, like we can we're getting
closer, man. So, keep at it. So, uh,
we'll have class we'll have a student le
class tomorrow. We'll we can we can work
through more of the uh the the build.
Um, but until then, this was fun. Uh,
this you guys did you guys did solid. I
was I'll emphasize for you guys to
continue to practice this, okay? And
then definitely look at the homework and
watch those watch those videos, read
those articles because it'll prepare
you. It'll it'll it'll get your mind
going. All right, so we got bounce.
Steal got class. I'll talk to you guys
tomorrow.
Sorry y'all. Have a good one. See y'all
in two seconds.
>> Two seconds. Peace.